.
>> ♪ ♪
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT!
OH, YES, YES, YES!
HAPPY THURSDAY.
MY FABULOUS FANTASTIC FURRY
FRIENDS.
LET'S TALK ABOUT MY FAVORITE
SUBJECT OTHER THAN GUS.
HOW IS GUS?
MY NEW PUPPY?
I AM GLAD YOU ASKED.
>> GUS, COME.
GUS, SIT.
GOOD BOY.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> GOOD BOYS.
>> Greg: LEARN HOW TO USE YOUR
PHONE.
TONIGHT'S TOPIC IS THE MEDIA AND
PUTTING THEIR THUMB ON THE SCALE
IN THE MID-TERM ELECTIONS.
A NEW STUDY FINDS THAT 90% OF
RECENT COVERAGE OF REPUBLICANS
ON THE ABC, CBS AND NBC EVENING
NEWS CASTS WERE NEGATIVE.
THAT'S AS SURPRISING AS JESSE
WATTERS CHUGGING ROGAINE.
GETS IN THE BLOOD TREME FASTER.
STREAM FASTER.
NOW THE NETWORKS ARE JACKED IT
UP.
THE REPUBLICANS ARE OUT OF POWER
AND THEY ARE THE UNDERDOG.
UNLESS IT'S JOE'S NOSE, NO ONE
IS DOING ANY PICKING OR EATING.
RATHER THAN FOCUS ON THE DEM'S
FAILURES ON CRIME AND THE
BORDER, THEY HANDLE THE
CHALLENGER'S CRITICISM.
IT'S HYSTERIA TO POINT OUT SUCH
FLAWS.
IN THE OLD DAYS THAT'S WHAT
JOURNALISTS DID.
NOW IT'S JUST REPUBLICANS.
GET OUT YOUR BINNOCK LULLARS.
-- ONLY 6 POSITIVE STATEMENTS
WERE MADE ABOUT HERSCHEL WALKER
VERSUS 50 NEGATIVES.
THE LEFT LEANING MEDIA DID NOT
LAY A GLOVE ON WARNOCK.
THERE WERE ONLY 2 POSITIVE
STATEMENTS FOR PENNSYLVANIA
SENATE CANDIDATE DR. OZ COMPARED
TO 9 NEGATIVE.
AND THOSE 2 POSITIVE STATEMENTS
WERE HIS NAME AND HIS
OCCUPATION.
THEN THERE IS POOR KARI LAKE
RUNNING FOR ARIZONA GOVERNOR.
NOT A SINGLE NICE THING TO SAY
ABOUT HER!
HELL, THEY COULD AT LEAST
COMPLIMENT HER BONE STRUCTURE.
HAVE YOU SEEN HOW SQUARE HER JAW
LINE IS?
NO WONDER ALL MY LEGO FIGURES
HIT ON HER.
HER FACE IS LIKE A GORGEOUS
RUBIC'S CUBE.
MAYBE IT'S JUST ME.
LOOK AT WHAT THEY DO FOR JOE
BIDEN WHO PUTS PREPARATION-H ON
HIS BLT.
THIS YEAR THE MEDIA TURNED OFF
THE CAMERAS BECAUSE LESS
COVERAGE IS BETTER THAN THAN
FACING THE DECEITFUL REALITY
THEY CREATED.
THERE IS JUST 34 MINUTES EVER
BIDEN COVERAGE AND HALF WAS HIM
TRYING TO GET HIS COAT ON.
-- OF.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> Greg: IT'S NOT HIS FAULT.
HE DIDN'T GET HIS DAILY
ALLOWANCE OF PONY TAIL IN A JAR.
REPUBLICANS ARE NOT RESPONDING
TO POLLS.
IT'S LIKE WHEN I LET KAT'S CALLS
GO TO VOICE MAIL.
PEOPLE DON'T RESPOND TO SURVEYS
ABOUT THEIR CHOICES BECAUSE
EVERYONE SAYS YOU ARE EVIL.
HE'S DRINKING GIN OUT OF
A BOTTLE AND WATCHING THREES
COMPANIES RERUN.
HOW DO YOU KNOW IF THE QUAL
CALLER IS REALLY A POLLSTER?
-- THE "NEW YORK TIMES" CALLS
THIS A WORE  WORRISOME PATTERN.
YOU RIP WHAT YOU SEW.
BITCHES!
THEY CAN'T TELL WHETHER THE
RACES WILL BE CLOSE OR GET BLOWN
OUT LIKE DANA'S HAIR AT HER HIGH
SCHOOL PROM.
HER HAIR WAS SO HIGH HER CURLING
IRON GOT A NOSE BLEED.
WHY SHOULD REPUBLICANS RESPOND
TO POLLS WHEN PEOPLE SAY THIS
ABOUT HIM.
>> A HISTORIAN WILL SAY WHAT IS
AT STAKE IS WHETHER WE WILL BE
A DEMOCRACY IN THE FUTURE.
WHETHER OUR CHILDREN WILL BE
ARRESTED AND KILLED.
WE ARE ON THE EDGE OF A BRUTAL
AUTHORITARIAN SYSTEM.
IT COULD BE A WEEK AWAY.
>> Greg: IF REPUBLICANS WIN
CHILDREN GET KILLED.
THAT THEY IS A HISTORIAN.
HOW THE HELL DID THAT HAPPEN?
DID HE SEND AWAY FOR A HISTORIAN
CARD FROM THE BACK OF
A WHEATIE'S BOX.
THEN I COULD BE A PHARMACIST AND
YOU DON'T WANT THAT.
BUT GOD, I DO.
THEN THERE IS THIS CREEP.
>> I READ A POLL YESTERDAY THAT
WHITE REPUBLICANS WOMEN ARE
GOING TO VOTE REPUBLICAN.
>> WHY.
>> IT'S LIKE ROACHES VOTING FOR
RAID.
>> [BOOING].
>> Greg: I LOVE HOW SHE LOOKS
UP.
SHE'S BEEN WAITING ALL DAY TO
SAY THAT.
COMPARING WHITE WOMEN TO ROACHES
ON THE "VIEW."
YOU ARE DUMBER THAN [BLEEP].
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Greg: SORRY, SORRY.
THAT'S NOT A COMPARISON AT ALL.
[LAUGHING].
I NEED TO GET SHOULD SLEEP.
IN THIS CLIMATE WHERE THE
DEMOCRACY ARE DEMONIZING VOTERS
IT'S NO SURPRISE THOSE ON THE
RIGHT KEEP THEIR MOUTHS SHUT AND
LIKE A TUESDAY WAY BACK WHEN IN
2016 THE MEDIA AND THE DEMS
WON'T KNOW WHAT HIT THEM.
-- DEMS.
LET'S WELCOME OUR GUESTS.
WHAT IS COOKING GOOD LOOK
SOMETHING FORMER CIA OPERATIVE,
MIKE BAKER.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Greg: HE CREATED MORE
TURNOVERS THAN A PASTRY CHEF,
FORMER NFL PLAYER JACK BREWER.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Greg: AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
AND TYRUS.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Greg: MIKE, HOW ARE YOU
DOING?
>> GOOD.
YOU MADE IT SOUND LIKE SITTING
AT HOME DRINKING GIN OUT OF
A BOTTLE IS A BAD THING.
THAT'S MY HOBBY.
>> Greg: I KNOW THE RESEARCH IS
NOT SURPRISING.
WE HAVE TO BE REMINDED THIS IS
MEDDLING AN ELECTION BY PUTTING
YOUR THUMB ON THE SCALE.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
POLING IS A LONG AND HONORED
TRADITION.
IT'S NEVER BEEN AS BAD IN TERMS
OF ITS LACK OF ABILITY TO
PREDICT ANYTHING THAN OVER THE
PAST DECADE:
IT'S WHAT YOU POINTED OUT.
WE GET THESE CALLS AND I DO THE
SAME THING.
I AM GOOD.
THANK YOU AM OR THERE HAVE BEEN
A COUPLE OF TIMES WHEN I SCREWED
WITH THEM.
I KNOW MY OWN LITTLE ABILITY TO
SCREW WITH A POLLSTER WON'T SWAY
THE WHOLE SURVEY.
THE POLITICS.
I DON'T KNOW THAT WE HAVE EVER
SEEN IT AS DYSFUNCTION AND
UNCIVIL AS IT IS NOW.
I DON'T MEAN TO SOUND GLOOMY BUT
IT'S DEPRESSING.
>> Greg: I LOVE SCREWING WITH
POLLSTERS.
I WILL HIDE HIS TOUPE IN THE
GREENROOM.
>> DRAGGED OFF BY YOUR DOG GUS.
>> EVERY TIME THEY CALL ME, I
PICK UP THE PHONE AND THINK.
DID THEY TAP MY PHONE?
I AM A BLACK CONSERVATIVE AND I
HANG UP RIGHT AWAY.
>> Greg: I HAVE NEVER GOTTEN
A CALL.
>> I GOT THREE.
I HATE THEM.
YOU NEVER KNOW WHO IS CALLING
YOUR PHONE.
PEOPLE SEE YOU ON TV.
I STAY AWAY.
I HOPE THE SILENT MAJORITY COMES
IN GROVES NEXT WEEK.
>> Greg: IT WILL BE HARD TO
TELL.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Greg: SPEAKING OF, TYRUS, YOU
SHOWED ME AN INTERESTING TEXT.
>> THEY DON'T JUST CALL ME.
THEY TEXT ME.
COULD WE CUE THIS UP?
GET THIS ON THE BIG SCREEN?
JOSHUA -- WHERE ARE MY GLASSES?
[BLEEP].
HI, GEORGE, USING GOVERNMENT
NAMES NOW.
IT'S JOSHUA WITH BLACK VOTERS
MATTER.
ELECTION DAY IS TUESDAY.
WE WON'T BLACK DOWN.
CLEVER.
I AM A BLACK REPUBLICAN, COOL?
THANKS FOR SHARING YOUR VIEW.
HAVE A GOOD DAY.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> HE WENT LIKE YOU, [BLEEP] AND
HUNG UP.
[LAUGHING].
THEY DON'T CARE IF THE BROTHERS
VOTE.
THEY ONLY CARE IF WE VOTE IN
THEIR TENT.
I WAS IN A WEIRD MOOD.
I DECIDED TO RESPOND.
I HAVE A SNEAKING SUSPICION
JOSHUA LOOKS MORE LIKE MY
SWEATSHIRT.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> Greg: [LAUGHING].
>> GREG, THIS IS CRAZY.
>> Greg: I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO
SAY.
[LAUGHING].
HOLY [BLEEP]!
>> THE BLACK VOTE IS MAKING SURE
BLACK MEN DON'T LET OUR
COMMUNITY DOWN.
THEY ARE GUILT TRIPPING US TO
VOTE FOR THESE POLICIES.
VOTE.
>> WE STICK OUT LIKE SORE
THUMBS.
>> YOU SAID THEY TAP YOUR PHONE.
>> I MET A BROTHER MIKE BAKER
BEFORE.
IT'S IN THE NAME.
>> Greg: DO YOU HAVE ANY TEXTS
YOU CAN SHOW US?
>> [LAUGHING].
>> SCROLL PAST THE PICTURES.
>> YOU WISH.
I HAVE ENGAGED IN DESPERATE END
OF TIMES HYPERBOLE BEFORE BUT
NEVER WHEN THINGS ARE GOING
WELL.
NOT WHEN THINGS ARE GOING MY
WAY.
THE KIDS ARE GOING TO DIE.
THE RAID COMMENT, LOOK, WHITE
SUBURBAN WOMEN DON'T ALWAYS LOVE
ME.
THEIR DADS SURE DO.
[LAUGHING].
THEY DON'T ALWAYS.
I LOVE YOU ANYWAY.
ROACHES TO RAID BY VOTING
REPUBLICAN AS A WHITE WOMAN YOU
ARE KILLING YOURSELF.
THAT'S DESPERATE END OF TIMES
HYPERBOLE.
IF YOU HAVE SOMETHING ELSE TO
SAY, YOU WOULD NOT GO WITH
SOMETHING THAT RIDICULOUS.
>> Greg: DIDN'T YOU ENJOY THE
WAY SHE LOOKED UP?
>> HER BEST LOOK.
>> WAITING ALL DAY IN THE
SHOWER.
PRACTICING IT.
>> SHE WANTED GENE TO COME OUT
WITH THE MICROPHONE SO HE COULD
DROP IT.
>> Greg: I JUST CAME UP WITH.
LIKE ROACHES VOTING FOR RAID.
IF YOU GOOGLE THAT STATEMENT 100
PEOPLE SAID IT BEFORE HER.
WE SOLVED A LOT OF THE WORLD'S
PROBLEMS.
>> END OF SHOW?
>> Greg: YES, I AM HEADING OUT.
ANOTHER 15 MINUTES OF AWKWARD
SILENCE.